[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité sec et pauvre en
eau les prochains mois seront marqués
une nouvelle fois par la sécheresse en
France un phénomène contre lequel essaie
de s'adapter les collectivités et les
sites touristiques la chasse à la fuite
d'eau est lancée comme nous le
montrerons vostv et via Occitanie dès le
début de ce journal
sauvage mais comestible la rédaction
Moselle TV nous emmènera elle en balade
en forêt à la découverte de ses
nombreuses plantes sauvages que l'on
peut cuisiner de précieuses astuces
culinaires avec le retour des beaux
jours et puis vous en mangerez beaucoup
c'est certain cet été les planches
apéritives font toujours recettes auprès
des Français rencontre dans ce journal
avec le vice champion de France en la
matière un militaire et oui reconverti
en fromager un sujet de thé vert arrête
et puis en fin de journal nous prendrons
un grand bol d'air frais dans la baie de
Somme là où ce côtoie et une flore
exceptionnelle comme nous le montrera où
est au TV la chaîne de la Voix du Nord
et du Courrier Picard en fin de journal
voilà de l'eau comme s'il en manquait
les prochains mois je vous le disais
dans les titres seront secs un peu
partout en France face au manque de
pluie qui s'annonce égale voie
supérieure à l'an passé les
collectivités tentent de réagir en amont
de la période estivale et pour ce faire
la chasse aux fuites et lancées exemple
dans les Vosges ou des travaux pour
remplacer des canalisations fuyantes
sont actuellement en cours objectif
éviter au maximum le gâchis de leur bleu
à ce sujet de Thierry Lasson regardez
au grand mot les grands remèdes les
travaux de renouvellement des
canalisations sont un des moyens activés
pour lutter contre la sécheresse sachant
que l'année 2022 restera comme la plus
chaude jamais enregistrée à ce jour en
France on estime à 20% la perte d'eau
potable sur la même période à cause des
fuites jusqu'à 35% dans les Vosges en
octobre dernier l'Agence de l'Eau Rin
Meuse a mis en place un plan d'aide dans
le Grand Est quelques 40 millions
d'euros sont mobilisés jusque fin 2023
sur les 200 km du réseau du syndicat
vint son concernés par des fuites coût
total des réparations 7 millions d'euros
dont 80% prise en charge par l'agence et
le Conseil départemental aujourd'hui
avec la loi qui évolue notamment par
rapport à la sécheresse en demande à ce
que les syndicats et des taux de
rendement qui soient de
85%. c'est ce l'objectif à atteindre
nous on vend 550000 mètres cubes d'eau
donc vous voyez 85% en gros plus de 450
000 mètres cubes ici à l'usine de
traitement de Removille l'eau potable et
distribue dans une trentaine de communes
aux alentours de Châtenois le
renouvellement du réseau aura donc un
impact bénéfique sur son activité les
travaux donc sur les tronçons fuya vont
nous apporter énormément de choses au
sein même de l'usine ce qu'on va du coup
moi prélever d'eau dans nos cinq
ressources également on aura une baisse
de la consommation d'énergie sur les sur
l'usine
et donc l'été dernier on était limite
limite pour alimenter la grippe parce
qu'il y a plus d'eau enfin il y a le
niveau du verre était vraiment très très
bas la Chavée près d'attigniéville et la
source d'eau principale de l'usine son
débit est de 200 mètres cubes d'eau par
heure en temps normal mais peut
descendre à 30 au moment de l'étiage un
phénomène naturel mais de plus en plus
marqué les craintes oui il y en a mais
l'usine vu qu'elle a cinq ressources
possibles et mobilisable on prend
vraiment l'eau où est où elle est
exactement et on compense l'usine de
rémovie l'aurait également droit à des
travaux pour augmenter sa capacité de
stockage le remplacement des conduites
fuyard de lui devrait se terminer en
automne il sera suivi de travaux
d'étanchéité sur une dizaine de
réservoir d'eau
voilà et vous allez le voir il n'y a pas
que les collectivités qui se mobilisent
pour préserver l'eau potable les lieux
de vacances aussi dans l'Hérault un
camping a décidé de sensibiliser les
touristes sur l'usage de l'eau un enjeu
d'actualité qui se décline en plusieurs
actions un reportage de Mélanie Caron
pourvient Occitanie regarde
un petit boîtier pour faire des
économies en trois ans ce camping a
installé 37 engins comme celui-ci le but
détecter immédiatement les fuites d'eau
pour éviter des pertes considérables
pour cette année on est limité à 87000
mètres cubes de consommation d'eau par
an et grâce ces boîtiers là donc sur
trois ans on a économisé à peu près 30
000 mètres cubes d'eau qui était dû à
des fuites et qu'on a pu localiser gaz
ces boîtiers là donc ça nous permet de
respecter ces arrêtés là en moyenne les
fuites représentent 30% de la
consommation d'eau un chiffre divisé par
3 pour le camping grâce à des alertes en
temps réel ici on avait une canalisation
qui a été fondue en deux qui a causé une
très grosse fuite soit une fuite de 33
mètres cubes par jour qu'on a pu réparer
rapidement grâce à la télérélève et ce
n'est pas tout pour sensibiliser les
vacanciers à l'écologie une zone de
permaculture a aussi été installée avec
l'aide des campeurs
sortira l'aromatique donc ça permet à la
fois de sensibiliser de faire quelque
chose de concret et de palpable on sort
un peu des de tous les tous les écrans
les réseaux sociaux et tout on fait
quelque chose de plus ancré avec la
nature et qui fait du bien des ateliers
ludiques comme ces hôtels à insectes qui
responsabilise les utilisateurs du site
comment ils vont vivre sans maison parce
que si ils ont pas de maison
ils vont être dans le froid le camping
prépare maintenant l'installation de son
propre maraîchage pour fournir sa
restauration
voilà l'eau encore dans ce journal qui
peut être aussi responsable de la
prolifération des moustiques tigres avec
le retour des beaux jours et la hausse
des températures l'insecte et surveillé
de très près par des agents spécialisés
comme vous le voyez sur ces images de la
rédaction de 7 à Limoges des opérations
de sensibilisation et d'éradication des
larves ont été notamment menées dans
plusieurs quartiers de la ville observés
pour la première fois l'an dernier à
Limoges le moustique tigre se développe
principalement dans des eaux stagnantes
prudence donc si vous disposez d'un
jardin ou d'un balcon
Bruno Le Maire était l'invité jeudi
matin de l'émission Face au territoire
sur TV5 Monde le ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique était
interrogé notamment sur la situation
économique du pays écoutons-le une
croissance à 0 à la fin de l'année 2022
02% au premier trimestre 2022 une forte
inflation est-ce que nous ne sommes pas
en situation de stagnation en France je
crois pas et je pense que c'est ce que
nous avons réussi à éviter au mois de
septembre dernier tout le monde me
disait il y aura une récession septembre
octobre novembre décembre tous les
spécialistes mais vous allez avoir une
récession vous serez en territoire
négatif comme on dit j'ai regardé des
chiffres je suis attentivement la
situation j'ai toujours défendu l'idée
que nous aurions une croissance positive
en 23 ce sera le cas l'inflation j'ai
indiqué que à partir de l'été elle
devrait commencer à refluer on a des
tout petits signaux de reflux ils sont
encore très modestes mais quand vous
regardez la moyenne de l'inflation
notamment la zone euro on voit que nous
commençons à maîtriser l'inflation c'est
essentiellement l'augmentation des taux
directeurs par la Banque centrale c'est
la politique monétaire c'est aussi le
fait que les prix du frais de baisse que
les prix de l'énergie baisse donc tout
ça commence à avoir un impact voilà
l'économie il en était également
question il y a une semaine avec Franz
Olivier Giesbert invité lui aussi de
face au territoire
l'éditorialiste et écrivain c'est
inquiété du niveau de la dette française
sur les antennes de TV5 Monde
écoutons-le pour voir un petit peu plus
loin que le bout de la Laurette que la
prochaine élection départementale ou
régionale et puis il faut essayer de
prendre des mesures pour le pays et pour
le pays on peut pas continuer à avoir un
pays qui dépense de plus en plus des
dépenses publiques enfin vous regardez
c'est l'heure c'est une sorte de record
mondial enfin c'est complètement
aberrant vous attribue à ça
bien sûr puisque
l'économie elle est plantée avec ça il y
a des déficits il y a l'endettement
enfin je veux dire la croissance elle
vient quand vous gérez bien on le sait
ça on l'a vu dans les années en 1958
elle est le général de Gaulle je dis pas
qu'on a il faut
mardi 9 mai nous célébrons la Journée de
l'Europe l'occasion pour les citoyens
d'en savoir un peu plus sur les
institutions du Vieux Continent une
série d'événements est organisée en
France et à Paris notamment au sein de
l'Europa expérience un lieu interactif
qu'on visitait récemment des jeunes
encadrés par la Maison de l'Europe des
Yvelines un reportage de Matisse
Godefroy et de Corentin Alonso pour
Radio sensation et TV 78
la raison principale c'était pour
instaurer la paix on apprend plus sur
l'Union européenne et voyager tout en
restant à Paris c'est possible tout au
long du parcours les visiteurs
découvrent des installations en réalité
augmentée et même un cinéma à 360 degrés
donc c'est un film de 8 minutes environ
qui est quand on passe en boucle ici en
bas et c'est un film qui parle un peu de
l'histoire de l'Europe pourquoi nous
Européens on s'est mis ensemble dans
cette union quelles sont les raisons et
donc il y a peu d'historique mais après
il y a aussi surtout aussi une partie
sur sur les défis futurs aussi autre
expérience interactive cette carte au
sol à l'aide d'une tablette les
visiteurs peuvent réviser leur
géographie et s'informer sur divers
projets européens partout sur le
continent donc aujourd'hui on est avec
des jeunes du programme Movin organisé
par la Maison de l'Europe c'est des
jeunes en insertion professionnelle qui
vont faire un stage
Erasmus
du blanc ou Malaga l'idée c'est que
ils partent en ayant connaissance de qui
finance ce projet et donc l'Union
européenne les institutions et les
différents États membres comment
s'organise l'Union européenne et à quoi
elle sert avant de partir en mobilité en
Irlande et en Espagne ces jeunes
originaire des Yvelines ont pu en
apprendre plus sur les institutions et
sur les euros députés français visite je
me suis rendu compte que l'Union
européenne a joué sur beaucoup d'aspects
que ce soit dans la société en France
mais dans tous les autres pays et que ça
c'était très important
on se rend pas compte forcément de
tout le spectre qui englobe l'Union
européenne outre Paris Strasbourg
Bruxelles Tallinn et Berlin ont déjà
leur Europa expérience objectif pour
lieu ouvrir un espace de ce type dans
chaque capitale européenne avant les
prochaines élections prévues en 2024
voilà et si vous visitiez les locaux
d'une entreprise avant pourquoi pas d'y
postuler cette initiative originale
était proposée il est à quelques jours
dans la Loire un moyen efficace pour
faciliter la rencontre entre employeur
et demandeurs d'emploi mais aussi dans
savoir un peu plus sur les métiers qui
recrutent images et propos recueillis
par Anthony verpillon pour TL7 dans la
Loire
ce que me disait les personnes là qui
déposaient leur CV et disent le problème
c'est que on passe par des filtres comme
les cabinets de recrutement qui nous
demandent des expériences et diplômes
qu'on n'a pas forcément alors que on
aimerait bien travailler dans tel ou tel
domaine qu'on est en reconversion et
c'est peut-être ça qui bloque le fait
que on n'arrive pas à mettre les gens en
face les uns des autres à discuter et à
se dire pourquoi pas essayer tout à fait
autre chose allez si je vous dis Silène
aille des ours egopode ou encore bardane
c'est non vous sont peut-être inconnus
il s'agit pourtant de plantes sauvages
parfaitement comestibles passionnés de
botanique et curieux étaient invité à
une promenade découverte près de Metz
une cueillette qui s'est ensuite
terminée par un atelier cuisine suivi
par Valentin Piovesan pour Moselle TV
regardez ce reportage passionnant
fleur les feuilles ils ne vont pas à
l'accueillette des champignons ce groupe
vaccueillir des plantes sauvages ce
matin il y a ceux qui découvrent
l'expérience et ceux qui s'y connaissent
un peu plus alors là on cueille juste la
pointe d'une feuille
pour laisser
le reste de la feuille et permettre aux
bulbes de l'ail des ours de se régénérer
passionné de botanique Jean alain est
venu chercher des connaissances
supplémentaires je savais qu'il y avait
des tas de plantes qu'on pouvait manger
mais après faut savoir les identifier il
faut savoir comment les ramasser
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire avec et ça
c'est quelque chose que je pense que que
l'on a perdu mais remis au goût du jour
par Valérie vous prenez une feuille et
vous la froissez entre vos doigts et
vous la sentez vous allez voir que sur
les plantes on n'a pas tous les mêmes
palais puis on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude de manger les mêmes choses
elle va leur expliquer leur donner tous
les conseils pour une cueillette réussie
line notamment une qu'on va pas ramasser
parce qu'elle est elle est encore trop
petite ou alors les plantes qui sont là
à part en abondance
je vais expliquer cette plante là on
peut la manger on peut faire si on peut
faire ça mais on va pas la ramasser
parce que là il y a 10 pieds aujourd'hui
le groupe va ramasser une dizaine de
plantes de sous-bois et de prairies
après deux heures de cueillette il
revienne le panier bien chargé
maintenant il faut préparer cette école
pour passer à table chacun met donc la
main la pâte en apéritif des toasts de
pesto d'ail des ours qui s'annonce
colorés en fondant à l'ortie pour le
dessert le tout accompagné d'un jus de
pomme là aussi à l'ortie j'utilise des
recettes traditionnelles
et j'incorpore des plantes sauvages
dedans au moment de la dégustation la
surprise gustative est au rendez-vous je
trouve que c'est succulent c'est
surprenant
de trouver des si bon goûts dans la
nature c'est des saveurs qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude
c'est sympa cuisiner des plantes
sauvages assez possible vous y penserez
donc pour votre prochaine réception et
bon appétit bien sûr
voilà tout à fait autre chose elle est
déjà une star du printemps et sera
assurément incontournable cet été la
saison de la fraise bat son plein en ce
moment en nouvelle-aquitaine la collecte
sous serre a même démarré il y a
plusieurs semaines une saison légèrement
plus avancée que les années précédentes
qui influent sur le prix de la barquette
au kilo Alix Fourcade a suivi une
Garriguette de la branche à l'assiette
un reportage pour TV7 la chaîne du
groupe sud-ouest
le prix final c'est bien le distributeur
qui
affiche donc c'est lui qui doit pouvoir
faire le dernier geste la productrice
s'appelle d'ailleurs les distributeurs à
mieux rémunérer les agriculteurs une
manière de défendre la filière française
face à la concurrence rude de l'Espagne
notamment un combat que mène aussi le
chef Fabien Beaufour du 133 à Bordeaux
il ne cuisine que de la fraise française
en version sucrée et salée on la connaît
plus sous le sucré mais nous on cuisine
l'acidité de la fraise va permettre
d'aller contrebalancer un foie gras une
poitrine de porc même du canard des fois
donc on peut jouer avec cette sucrosité
le chef propose d'ailleurs en ce moment
un gaspacho de fraises au menu alors on
a un peu de poivrons pour la base
concombre du pain toasté et les galettes
une belle recette que l'on pourra
déguster jusqu'à la fin de la saison de
la fraise en octobre
des fraises mais aussi des kiwis des
murs mais surtout de la charcuterie et
du fromage direction maintenant la
Bretagne dans cette édition à la
rencontre du vice champion de France
écoutez bien de la planche apéritive et
oui la première édition de ce drôle de
concours s'est tenu il y a quelques
jours à Paris mais Daillé d'argent donc
un militaire reconverti en fromager un
sujet appétissant de Capucine co la
guillochin pour TVA Rennes
cet homme est un expert
il est même l'un des meilleurs français
mais saurez-vous deviner dans quel
domaine
Gauthier Ducret vice champion de France
de la planche apéritive 2023 et oui la
planche apéro a désormais son concours
national j'ai décidé de faire un bouquet
de fleurs
en fromage et charcuterie le brétien a
présenté ce qu'on appelle trois tableaux
sur le thème du printemps un seul mot
d'ordre l'équilibre car oui la planche
apéritive c'est tout un art j'avais mes
idées en tête
fallait juste
respecter le timing pour tout mettre ça
sur un plateau
de la marchande reconverti en fromager
depuis seulement deux ans mais alors
c'est quoi le secret de la bonne planche
la bonne planche pour moi voilà il faut
que ce soit une planche déjà colorée le
beau attire le bon forcément
il faut que ce soit très équilibré au
niveau des fromages qu'on met qu'on
propose et au niveau de la charcuterie
on rajoute un peu de sucre pour
justement parfois casser le côté salé
que peut avoir la charcuterie parfois
voilà il faut toujours qu'on puisse
grignoter et qu'il y ait toujours une
envie de de revient de quoi
la star ici c'est la planche qui
représente près de 50% du chiffre
d'affaires de la boutique c'est goûtu
voilà c'est varié c'est c'est des
paysages les plateaux magnifiques quoi
le commerçant retentera le concours
l'année prochaine en attendant il
continuera de s'entraîner rien que cet
été il devrait en concocter plusieurs
centaines
voilà qui donne envie allez sans
transition direction la Corse ou se
dérouler l'une des manches du
championnat de France du LM l'occasion
de découvrir c'est très belles images
aériennes de nos confrères de télépaïsé
l'île de beauté et son cadre féérique
accueilli pour la première fois un tel
événement propos récolter par
Marc-Antoine muccielli écouter les
meilleurs pilotes sont là vous avez la
crème de la crème ce sont vraiment les
les plus les plus précis vous avez
vraiment des très bons pilotes et des
très bons pilotes corses également qui
sont aujourd'hui compétiteurs ici au
niveau des règles cette compétition on
se pose sur l'herbe plusieurs avions
deux types de catégories expliquez-nous
un petit peu ces réglementations
d'aujourd'hui alors l'objectif est
décoller très court et d'atterrir très
court on va additionner les deux
performances et c'est ça qui fait la
performance totale
voilà et dans la Sarthe ce sont les
moteurs des vieilles automobiles qui
vont Misser dans les rues du Mans pour
la 38e édition des courses des deux et
cinq litres objectifs parcourir une
courte distance en consommant le moins
d'essence possible mais aussi et surtout
se faire plaisir en observant ses
mythiques voitures des images de Colin
Hansel pour lmtvart la passion le
partage ça fait une trentaine d'années
qu'on collectionne la que soit les
voitures les motos ou les vélos
donc j'aime bien voilà et pour ceux qui
préfèrent les performances un peu plus
sportives il vous faudra patienter
encore jusqu'au 10 et 11 juin pour
suivre cette fois-ci les 24 Heures du
Mans
elle est sans transition vont une page
culture dans cette édition avec d'abord
ces images du journal La Marseillaise
Capu filmer la restauration de deux
œuvres monumentales du plasticien Victor
Vasarely à Aix-en-Provence un travail
évidemment minutieux qui s'étalera
jusqu'au mois de juillet au cœur de la
Fondation créé par l'artiste précision
au micro de Charles waste de la
Marseillaise notre travail consiste en
la compréhension en fait du support sur
lequel on intervient on commence
toujours par procéder à une phase de
test préalable pour comprendre les
matériaux et comprendre également avec
quel type de méthode est-ce qu'on peut
intervenir c'est la raison pour laquelle
en fait vous avez le labo dans l'alvéole
d'à côté donc il y a une très grosse
phase en chimie où on procède à des
prises de mesure pH conductivité
réflexion de la surface etc pour
vraiment être sûr qu'on se cale au mieux
sur l'aspect esthétique de l'œuvre sa
composition
voilà et puis Yasmine Gata et la
nouvelle lauréate du Prix littéraire de
la Closerie des Lilas la romancière est
récompensée pour son dernier livre
intitulé Le testament du Prophète publié
aux éditions bouquins dans cet ouvrage
l'auteur raconte entre réalité et
fiction le retour pour le moins
compliqué d'une romancière de renom dans
son village natal félicitations à elle
pour ce prix voilà allez on ferme ce
journal avec une balade au cœur de la
Baie de Somme la rédaction de Wéo TV la
chaîne de la Voix du Nord et du Courrier
Picard nous conduit à la découverte des
richesses insoupçonnées du littoral
picard estuaire de 72 km² regorge vous
allez le voir de nombreux secrets une
sortie au grand air et au rythme des
marées que nous propose Jérôme Aubron
regardez
allez vas-y pousse comme ça tac et on
pousse bien comme ça il faut mettre la
main à la pâte pour poser les yeux sur
ce que la Baie de Somme cachant son sein
c'est le départ d'une visite guidée
entre terre et mer c'est ça qui est
passionnant c'est que ce sont en fait
des alvins Alvin crevettes crabes une
vie cachée et invisible témoin de tout
un écosystème c'est une découverte
effectivement cette vie cachée et
complètement invisible c'est vrai que il
faut absolument venir sur place pour se
rendre vraiment compte de tout ce qu'il
y a à découvrir la découverte de ces 72
km de B se poursuit sur l'estran là où
le sable est chaque jour recouvert par
une mer qui façonne le paysage et
nourrit la faune locale à l'image de ces
huîtris venus se repaître de quelques
crustacés
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est le fait
que c'est chaque jour renouvelé en fait
on sait jamais exactement quel va être
la surprise que la mère nous a apporté
que la marée basse nous va faire va nous
faire découvrir en fait au fil de la
balade une chasse se met en place quand
les premières traces de phoque
apparaissent on peut voir qu'il y en a
plusieurs par là on va aller regarder ça
ça veut dire que peut-être qu'il
reviendrait par ici tout à l'heure et
c'est quand la mer monte qu'elle reprend
ses droits que ses habitants bien connus
du site cherchent un nouveau lieu où
s'installer un moment idéal pour ceux
qui traquent la belle image bah ça fait
toujours quelque chose de pouvoir voir
des animaux comme ça je pense que quel
que soit le type d'animaux et voilà de
voir des fucks en médecine c'est
incroyable un spectacle incroyable qui
rappelle au passage la nécessité de
protéger la biodiversité locale on a des
individus des mammifères marins une
faune particulière sauvage qui vit ici
qu'il faut aussi dont il faut aussi
prendre conscience et être attentif donc
tu vois c'est cette notion du beau qui
vient te toucher et qui fait que ouais
ça t'ouvre un peu les yeux en fait
ouvrir les yeux sur la richesse de la
Baie de Somme sur une mère nourricière
et indomptable sur la place de l'homme
dans cet équilibre c'est peut-être là
que réside la plus belle découverte
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi le Grand Journal des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]